so super excited to be heading to
Antarctica later in November and I'm
going to be looking after a very very
small team on a very small island on the
Antarctic Peninsula so we will be
receiving many visitors during the
season and sharing with them the history
of British
um
presence in Antarctica so there's uh
Huts there that was lived in over winter
throughout the year which is one of the
first bases that the UK set up it was
actually during the second World War
and since then and this is what the
Island's going to look like so there's
there's going to be a lot happening it's
now a museum so the UK and toxic
Heritage Trust that I'm going to be
working for is responsible for
preserving this Hut which is the
flagship Hut and also
um five others on the peninsula and so
we're going to be going down to share
this story with the visitors to show
them around to tell the history of the
British presence but also the history of
science so this museum is actually where
the birth of British Science in
Antarctica they were studying the ozone
layer at that time which went on to go
into the British Antarctic Survey and
actually discover the hole in the ozone
layer so there's a lot of history there
but a lot of excitement as well we've
got a very large penguin Colony we've
got lots of visitors and experience of
living in a remote and wonderful place
okay
um you've been obviously swatting up
haven't you
um tell me more about the space that
you'll be working Within so we're going
to be working it's about the size of a
football field so it's very small island
in fact when I first applied for the
role got through the first interview and
realized exactly how small it was I took
a moment to have a deep breath and think
is this really for me
that it's a beautiful area surrounded by
mountains glaciers the sea and it's
quite Rocky so there's snowy snowy yep
certainly When we arrive there might be
quite a lot of snow maybe even sea ice
coming in for the beginning and the end
of the season but I think it does melt
off four months you're going to be there
for about that one of the biggest
challenges going to be have you met the
girls that you're going to be with we
are we've met them briefly yes so we had
uh so we're spending four months in a
hot size and football pitch with
somebody that you've never met before
really that is correct Grace what could
go wrong what could go wrong indeed yeah
no I think well so far we've all been
getting on really well it's a great team
and the UK Antarctic Heritage Trust
particularly focuses on that in
selection is like really how do we get
on together who's going to work
effectively together so they're maybe so
who comes along to look at the um the
museum and the like so there's a lot of
cruise ships that visit every year
there's potentially up to 18 000
visitors and it's individuals who have
been lucky enough to either afford a
cruise or you know save up and be part
of one of the visiting ships also a lot
of sailing boats as well that visit so
that will be where you get your supplies
from as well and like there's a lot of
supplies that have been shipped out in
advance and in fact I think we're going
to be living in a way a similar life to
those original explorers lots of tinned
food baking Breads and but then some
fresh supplies off the ship what's the
plan for Christmas Day
to be seen I know that there's a keen
interest in mince pies from the team so
hopefully I don't last forever don't
they so there's no worry there so there
might be some that are sent down yeah oh
fantastic um impact of uh climate change
so that's one of the areas that we look
at so the penguin colony is one that we
monitor when we're there that's one of
the jobs that we're going to be having
and seeing both how the visitors affect
their breeding but also the changing
climate and there's going to be also a
biological survey that takes place this
year as well by a conservation biologist
is one of the team and she's going to be
looking at that so certainly Antarctica
is heavily affected by climate change as
are we in the UK and there's a very
close relationship with the two so
whilst it seems very far away actually
what we're doing here at home affects
the continent and vice versa and how do
you interact with the Penguins what's
the plan
so we have to keep a safe distance from
them to protect them as well and it's
predominantly monitoring so seeing how
the breeding goes are they successful
counting the eggs counting the chicks
and counting to see how many actually
sort of hatch to survival level but
they're we're living around them and
they're interacting with our lives as
much as we are with them when we're
there worried about Cabin Fever
it's a very aware of and possibly one of
the the largest challenges but we're
going to be super busy so I'm I'm sure
that actually that's going to be the
predominant Focus what are you most
looking forward to
the Wilderness environments so for me
I'm an adventurer I love the outdoors I
love nature I've worked all my life in
to preserve these natural spaces and the
opportunity to go south and to see this
environment is unique and something that
I've been looking forward to forever so
what does the post office element come
in so that is something that was set up
when the UK first established this base
and it's been operational for the
duration of the time there so it's a
working post office like any that you'd
have here and the visitors that come to
the island are able to post letters and
send a memory back to their loved ones
at home and how long does that take it's
not next day delivery is it it's not
next day delivery no it's about five to
six weeks so it's not it's not too long
and it's the same price if not cheaper
than sending it within the UK okay and
as far as the museum is concerned I mean
who came up with these ideas in in the
first place and how how has it managed
to keep going for such a long time how
long has it been there
so the base was actually set up in
1944 okay and yeah so it hasn't been
operational the whole time it did
actually fall into disrepair for a
number of years and then when the
Antarctic treaty came in there was a lot
of looking at what bases were there
which ones should remain and which ones
shouldn't so a small group of
individuals set up to preserve British
Heritage and Antarctica and be able to
tell the stories of the history so the
museum is actually part of that it's a
Living Museum it talks about what life
was like there but also about the
science there's um uh some of the
Machinery that they used for data
collection and the science at the time
including one called The Beastie so I
think that's something that people might
be and that sounds interesting
um do your friends and family think
you've lost your mind
I think they're actually
um quite familiar with my wonders around
the world so this is something that I've
been looking forward to or trying to
undertake for many years and I was
actually trying to plan a trip to the
Arctic when this job opportunity arose
so it's not unfamiliar but certainly not
something they would be under so we'd be
able to talk to us while you're there
there's no internet connection we have
satellite comms and we will be having a
Blog so on the UK Antarctic Heritage
Trust website you'll be able to follow
us I'm not sure whether or not the
satellite connection will allow Live
Connections or not well we'll give it a
go and send us a postcard anyway from
that post office just for the breakfast
show Sky I'm sure we'll get it I'm sure
we'll get it exactly safe travels thank
you very much indeed for joining us
thanks a lot